heading down here yes sir down the ramp
and we have people lined up on the left
over here
some union leaders and workers
Your Mark is going to be the blue one to
the left
you've got a blue Mark and that's okay I
got I'll stand my blue Mark and then I'm
going to say loady's money yes sir I'm
going to I'll help you get started
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
it is April 5th 2023 we are live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and locals
want to thank all of you who are tuning
in on Rumble these days our live stream
numbers have been absolutely bananas
basically matching if not sometimes
surpassing uh YouTube by the end of the
day which is absolutely incredible
considering we've got about 2 million
subscribers on YouTube and about 400 000
on Rumble it shows you that the tide is
changing so very appreciative of that
and if you want to play along during the
show as always you can join us right now
at
reubenreport.locals.com and there is an
iOS an Android app and as always we'll
have a post game wrap-up show for our
paid subscribers uh I do want to note
out of that cold open there that uh you
know we can mock Joe Biden for not
knowing where he's going having a
Handler tell him where he has to stand
and everything else but my team does do
a similar thing when I come up here in
the morning Daphne walks me to the desk
you're going to sit in that chair
Phoenix always says Dave you have to
look into the camera over there broccoli
says Dave you're going to hold your pen
in your left hand you're a lefty and
Connor is in charge of making sure that
I don't fall out of the seat so you know
we can mock Joe Biden but who who of us
is not LED around by a bunch of handlers
to tell us what to do and where to be in
the rest of it uh the theme today ladies
and gentlemen I don't know if you know
there's a lot of craziness in the news
cycle right now and we're going to try
to uh obviously cover the Trump stuff
but do it in a I would say more of a
blue sky way uh in that you know I
always talk about this kind of slow
descent to hell that we're on that that
there's a portion of the country it's
it's largely of the progressive left but
it's corporate media it's big Tech this
thing that is just dragging us to hell
they keep coming they never stop
drag queens with kids
woke this everyone's racist they don't
understand basic reality related to
economics or foreign policy like it just
keeps coming now it's coming for
literally an ex-president to try to
arrest the freaking guy and I think we
have to occasionally
say enough is enough maybe we should all
be doing it every freaking day but we
need a return to the Great American
culture that we had for a long time I am
46 years old I was born in 1976 I'm a
child of the 80s and the 90s when we had
put so much of this stuff to bed I keep
saying man if we could just rewind if we
could just go back give me a time
machine find me a DeLorean find me one
point 21 gigawatts of power some
plutonium from the libyans and let's go
back to 1995 and guess what things would
be better and if we knew what we know
now about how wacky things we're going
to get and how reality would become so
unreal
perhaps we would have fought a little
bit harder to keep that goodness when
nobody thought it was cool to be racist
or homophobic or anything else and we
kept the crazy extremists out of the
government and out of culture and
everything else so we're going to talk a
little bit about the culture part and
the policy part and how it relates to
the to the rot that is happening in this
country which would lead us to a moment
like we're in right now where apparently
half the country thinks it's okay to
arrest a former president of the United
States who is running for president
again and as I said yesterday several
times and I'll have to keep repeating it
does not even matter all the specifics
of the payment to the porn star or the
other misdemeanors that they turned into
felonies or anything else once we go
down this path once America says we
arrest
former presidents
the pool of people who will ever want to
be president will become much thinner
right it will be much more shallow and
as that gets more shallow then the few
people who are willing to get in will
never want to let go of power because it
will end very poorly of them
so as you know politics is Downstream of
culture culture matters and that's what
we're going to be talking about today
and linking it to what's going on with
Trump and everything happening
politically before we do that let me
talk to you guys about ramp you know you
feel like your finance software isn't
cutting it do you want the latest and
greatest in financial software to simply
spend help you save time and keep you
from getting trapped in busy work check
out ramp ramp is the corporate card and
expense management software designed to
help you save time and put money back in
your pocket ramp gives Finance teams
unprecedented control and insight into
company spend with ramp you're able to
issue cards to every employee with
limits and restrictions and automate
expense reporting so you can stop
wasting time at the end of every month
ramp's accounting software automatically
collects receipts and categorizes your
expenses in real time so that you don't
have to you'll never have to chase down
a receipt again and your employees will
no longer spend hours submitting expense
reports the time you'll save each month
on running on employee expenses will
allow you to close your books eight
times faster ramp saves you money
businesses that use ramp save an average
of 3.5 percent in the first year and now
get 250 dollars when you join ramp just
go to ramp.com Reuben that's ramp
ramp.com Ruben I assume you know how to
spell Reuben all right so I thought a
nice way to frame the show today would
be a little bit of throwback stuff so
first we're going to throw back to a
mere five years ago five years ago in
some ways feels like a lifetime ago it
was before covid it was before a lot of
this craziness but craziness was on the
horizon and then there was and there was
obviously some degree of craziness but
five years ago here is Roseanne Barr you
remember Roseanne Barr comedian Roseanne
Barr we were quite friendly for some
time I I don't know that I've ever I
think maybe I've said this on the show
once or twice before uh but Roseanne for
a little while after I left the Young
Turks Network she had a studio in Los
Angeles and I was shooting the show out
of her studio for about four or five
months that was before we built our
first home studio so Roseanne's been
very good to me over the years I like
Roseanne a lot she's she's an edgy
irreverent comic uh you know it's funny
that she's painted now as sort of this
right-wing Maniac you may remember from
back in the day this has got to be
around I don't know maybe 1995 or 1996
when the original Roseanne show was on
television the first gay kiss ever on
network television was on Roseanne's
show it was her and I forget the actress
the blonde actress that it was with but
it was a lesbian kiss not a lesbian bar
on Roseanne's show and now she's a
right-wing Maniac anyway let's flash
back to five years ago here is Roseanne
are on Jimmy Fallon's show talking about
her support for Trump this is right
before she got canceled
it couldn't be a bigger thing uh but
then also with a big hit comes people
that aren't so happy as well if you say
that you're a supporter of Donald Trump
or oh yeah people are mad about that
yeah you know I don't give up
yeah I mean is that how you do it
everybody has well everybody had to
choose for themselves according to their
own conscience who they thought was the
lesser of two evils
you know everybody chose that so I'm not
gonna put anybody down who didn't vote
like me this is America it's a free
country and you know when you uh weigh
it all together you know I think I just
felt like we needed a whole new thing
all the way bottom to top yeah okay so
Roseanne was a trump supporter and as
you may know when she was on that show
five years ago this was after they had
reboot the sitcom right so they brought
Roseanne back it was the number one
sitcom In America the number one comedy
show in America this is a mere five
years ago that's while this interview is
taking place and then she tweeted out
something that got her canceled a couple
days later you'll see why I'm putting
this all together for you a little info
on that uh from ABC ABC has announced
that it is canceling the sitcom Roseanne
after the show star Roseanne Barr
compared former Obama senior advisor
Valerie Jarrett to an ape on Twitter in
the since deleted tweet Barr wrote
Muslim Brotherhood and Planet of the
Apes had a baby referring to Jared now
Roseanne Barr is not racist it's it's
absolutely ridiculous the whole purpose
of the Roseanne show was the show blue
collar workers and they had black
friends and gay friends and blah blah
blah she made a joke she even said to me
and I think she said it publicly after
she didn't even know Valerie Jarrett was
black like does doesn't even matter but
the point is the point is she had the
number one show in America she was a
trump supporter she tweets out something
let's just say it was stupid or mildly
offensive or or highly offensive they
kicked her off the show the show
continued it subsequently has been
canceled but they kicked her off
Roseanne they kicked Roseanne off
Roseanne called it the Connors then the
show failed shortly after that uh and
this is what the machine seems to do and
the Machine right now seems to be doing
it to Donald Trump himself so now I
thought okay well Roseanne's a good uh
way to jump off here because as I said
guys I I'm a child of the 80s and the
90s and I remember when Roseanne's show
was on air and I remember what culture
used to be like and that we could laugh
at things together and that nobody cared
about anyone's skin color and nobody
really cared about anyone's genitals or
anything else and I want to show you in
a moment a commercial from the 80s that
I think really encapsulates that quite
beautifully before we do let me talk to
you about tax Network USA real quick if
you owe back taxes or have unfiled
returns don't let the government take
advantage of you tax Network USA is a
Nationwide Tax resolution firm who can
protect your rights and settle your back
taxes in some cases they can even zero
out your balance they're experts in all
IRS programs and under understand tax
law so you don't have to over the last
14 years tax Network USA has saved over
a billion in back taxes for their
clients they can even file your yearly
return to protect you from audits the
Biden Administration will be overhauling
the IRS God help us all so they can Levy
bank accounts garnish wages and uh
Social Security benefits like never
before they can even seize your property
like your business home or retirement
accounts whether you owe a few thousand
or a few million they can help you even
if you haven't filed in years they can
help you even if you have a payment
arrangement they can help you call the
Patriots a tax Network USA now or visit
taxnetworkusa.com Dave okay so let's
flash back when I talk about this slow
descent to hell that things culturally
seem to get worse and worse and worse
where were we a mere 20 years ago a mere
30 years ago we were in a pretty good
spot so check out this ad that came
across Phoenix's desk the other day and
he's like Dave we got to figure out a
way to get this into the show this is an
ad from Gillette in the 9 1980s and note
the positive role models and the sort of
pleasantness that we could do in a
nationwide ad in the 80s
you're looking sharp you're looking good
you've come so far
we know how to make
the most of who you are always
[Music]
I'm so many faces it's plain to see
we give you all we have to give
where the race is wrong
[Music]
to let Contour plus with lubricating
strip to the best a man can get
powerful right like that was a
commercial in the 80s that feels like
it's from another planet Phoenix just
said to me that makes me sad and I
wasn't even born in the 80s he doesn't
even remember the 80s but it was real
that's what it was like back in the 80s
the things that you could do you could
surf you could get a job you could get
married what else could you do you could
work out back then run on a beach you
could go to space you could shot put
that's what we were doing the point is
you could be proud of accomplishing
things you could do things in your life
generally it seemed like you could do
them better if you were fully shaven I
would have struggled a little bit but
like you know keeping it tight where I
can but the point is that we used to
have a culture I mean think about it
Gillette right and I'm sure Gillette was
owned by it and probably still is now
owned by a massive Corporation Beyond
Gillette just Gillette
um and they put money in advertising to
show people to be proud to show people
you can accomplish things you can build
a family you can find someone that loves
you you can have kids it's so counter to
what is being pushed on us all the time
now
I'd like to juxtapose you know I like
the word juxtapose I'd like to juxtapose
that with an ad from Gillette in 2019. a
mere four years ago and you tell me
is the message of Gillette in the 80s or
is the message of Gillette in 2019 a
better more positive message take a look
bullying the metoo movement against
sexual harassment masculinity
is this the best a man can get
is it
a problem we can't hide from it
harassment is taking over it's been
going on far too long
we can't laugh at all
what I actually think she's trying to
say making the same old excuses boys
will be boys will be boys but something
finally changed regarding sexual assault
sexual harassment
and there will be no going back
because we
we believe in the best in men men need
to hold other men accountable smile
sweetie come on
to say the right thing
to act the right way not cool not cool
some already are
and weighs big foreign
[Music]
but some is not enough
we treat each other okay okay
because the boys watching today
will be the men of tomorrow
foreign
[Music]
first off most of the kids in those
commercials aren't going to be able to
shave ever because they're being pumped
with estrogen but that's a whole other
story all that estrogen and soy these
days uh that's one thing but you see how
in the course of 30 years they went from
you know you're doing the best you can
try to get out there fix your life find
someone who loves you accomplish what
you want to accomplish to this weird
like feel kind of guilty about what
you've done and you're by the nature of
being a man you are associated with mean
things and that means you must be a
misogynist and somehow you must also
kind of be racist but they're also
trying to sell freaking freaking like
shaving cream you know what I mean like
oh it's just so silly but it but it
really has leaked into everything so the
real reason we wanted to show you those
two is because uh Bud Light you may have
seen this over the last couple days Bud
Light which I thought you know we're
always told is the drink of men watching
football eating wings they're new spokes
man
is Dylan Mulvaney now Dylan Mulvaney as
far as we know we can Google it again
Brock you can do it today does Dylan
Mulvaney still have a penis Dylan
Mulvaney Brock Google it
Dylan Mulvaney is the woman right like
the trans woman who is in all these
videos who Joe Biden brought to the
White House and celebrated his or her
trans whatever okay fine but she he is
now the new spokesman for Bud Light I
don't know what Brock just came up with
but he's cracking up over there so I'm
going to find out as we play this for
you this is Dylan Mulvaney new Bud Light
spokesperson
hi
hi that's right got some Bud Lights for
us
I kept hearing about this thing called
March Madness and I thought we were all
just having a hectic month but it turns
out it has something to do with sports
and I'm not sure exactly which sport but
either way it's a cause to celebrate
this month I celebrated my day 365 a
Womanhood and Bud Light Sent Me possibly
the best gift ever a can with my face on
it check out my Instagram story to see
how you can enjoy March Madness with Bud
Light and maybe win some money too love
ya
cheers go team whatever team you love I
love too
okay
love ya okay break a leg all right so
let's let's put aside that there
obviously is some level of satire there
and he or she is trying to be funny and
whatever the point is what is Bud Light
doing by sending him or her
beer and putting her face or his face on
this thing and everything else does that
sell any beer right does does anyone is
there anyone on Earth who suddenly is
like
I do like light beer I like my four
percent Connor you're the Beer Drinker
here of course you're a Coors guy no you
like your ipas you like your uh what do
you like what do you like
Lagunitas okay Lagunitas does not have
a trans woman or whatever trying to sell
you on Lagoon eat this beer it has a
nice hoppy taste a little bitterness
it's an IPA there you go but so what
really is going on here and that's what
that's what I'm saying this has more to
do with culture than even selling
products or anything else what has
happened to us that Bud Light which was
it was the football beer right it was
the it was it was for men and all that
uh well now it's going to this pretend
woman who's also at the same time
mocking women in her behavior is
behavior whatever God it's so stupid uh
it's telling you that something really
is wrong with our culture and I think
that actually ultimately does I can
connect this to the drum thing a culture
that is deeply broken will find the
wrong enemies all the time we'll get to
that in just a moment but let's continue
with sort of what seems to be wrong here
you know this guy Charlemagne the God
that's what they call him I have trouble
I've told you I can't call him what's
his real name Leonard something Leonard
something Leonard McKelvey I guess is
his real name he was on Andrew Schultz
who's a comedian he was on his podcast
and they were playing some clips of
Colin Kaepernick of course you guys know
Colin Kaepernick former NFL player who
went beyond bananas woke uh he's no
longer in the league and now is
basically one of the leading proponents
of wokism everywhere everything's racist
including his adopted parents his white
adopted parents who adopted this little
black boy he's going off on them these
days uh here are Schultz and uh mcelvey
discussing just that
this is hilarious no no Colin Kaepernick
says he knows his white adoptive parents
loved him but they were very problematic
things that occurred during his
upbringing oh your hair is not
professional oh you look like a little
Thug
become I said that too yeah and those
become spaces where it's like okay how
do I navigate the situation now but it
also is informed why I have my hair long
today the grown-up version of Eve wanted
to go back in time and give young Colin
a lot of hugs and I was really moved and
saddened by the level of self-awareness
oh my God
a parent didn't like their kids haircut
never has happened in history welcome to
being a child and having parents and
that's what your mom's saying to you
right now probably as a black man who
used to be a black boy black teenager uh
when I had an afro and I was getting
cornrows and stuff same thing happened
and I don't have white pants
and a black dad who did not like that
especially when I started wearing Chuck
Taylor's and Snoop Dogg had that murder
case well it was made me especially when
I was getting in trouble in school he
made me cut my hair because for whatever
reason me having a big afro and wanting
to get cornrows and wearing Chuck
Taylors equated to me wanting to be a
thug or I'll never be able to get a good
job or anything else like I don't think
that's something that's exclusive to
race yeah but when you see everything
through the lens of racism you're gonna
find it and that's what he sees right
here yeah that's quite right I mean it's
it's an offshooter saying I say all the
time if you if you see everything
through that lens then you'll always
find racism and and what the problem is
then when real racism racism shows up
you don't even know what to do with it
um I should note that that they they
have that podcast together Charlemagne
the God and uh Schultz that's their
co-podcast I think I said it was uh
Schultz's podcast
um but what's interesting about this
also is that uh Kaepernick is doing
something that I think many uh young
people youngish people are doing and
he's not even that young anymore right
he's got he's got to be in his probably
late 30s at this point uh which is that
you're focused on what you perceive to
have happened to you many many years ago
like if you are an adult if you are
somewhere I'm not even talking about in
your 20s I'll Grant everyone the
weirdness of the 20s once you are in
your 30s let's say if you are still
going man that thing happened to me in
sixth grade in sixth grade I was bullied
by that guy or that teacher wasn't nice
to me or my parents wanted me to pull my
pants up you have a you have an actual
psychological condition that you have to
deal with that you have to actually
confront you know I remember when I was
in like sixth grade one of the one of
the trends was that we were wearing
boxer shorts that were from colleges so
it would have like the College
University Indiana on the back Penn
State on the back kind of on your butt
and you would wear your pants kind of
low and I grew up in the suburbs of New
York okay uh I don't think it was a thug
thing or anything else but I remember my
dad being like you look like a
what are you doing and telling me to
don't walk out of the house like that
was that was he uh being somehow racist
or abusive or something like that of
course not of course not your parents
are supposed to try to set some level of
an example but I think what we've done
here is we've infantilized so many
adults that Kaepernick sort of in a way
he almost gets off on this idea that
again his parents his adopted parents
were white
they were white do you think that they
were racist in any way but he he is so
sucking on the teat of racism he can't
get off that thing but we you all know
people like this like that people that
are just like hung up on that thing that
happened to the bat them back then and I
think we now have a culture that seems
to be unable to grow up unable to deal
with the world as it is would prefer to
destroy the known world and rebuild it
and these people are not particularly
good at building anything and then this
leaks into all forms of government so I
want to show you this picture this is
former
fortunately former FBI director James
Comey you remember James Comey check out
his T-shirt back in 2017 elect more
women now he was appointed by Trump and
fired by Trump but he was FBI director
at this point elect more women and it's
one of those things it sort of sounds
right okay I guess elect more women I
don't know do more women want to be in
politics are women somehow inherently
better at politics than men or does it
actually have something to do with your
individual thoughts and actions and
actually your uh your gender is
completely irrelevant but the question
is what are the political consequences
of this modern American culture when
people just wear these meaningless
slogans you know and they wear black
lives matter science we believe in
science or no one is illegal as they
have a fence in front of their house and
all of those things uh well James Comey
again former FBI director brought in by
why Trump also fired by Trump uh here's
what he tweeted yesterday as Trump was
hauled into court in New York City
another good day
so the former FBI director has made it
clear his feelings are that a former
president of the United States should be
brought in and indicted by a New York
City D.A on
quote unquote trumped up charges and
that is good for America it's actually
terrible for America it might be good
for him because it might be good for the
Deep state right it might be good for
the UNA party that somehow always wins
but it is not good for the country uh
here's an image of course of trump
yesterday so this is Trump at the
courthouse yesterday that's sort of an
iconic image he did not get the the
picture uh you know the main picture
against the wall so that's that's the
picture we're going with right now but
now we have to show you some of the ways
that the media is covering this stuff
because once to link all this together
you take a bunch of adults who don't
know how to deal with the world as it is
once you take a bunch of people who
think everything is racist all the time
a bunch of people who are afraid to get
out there and do something for
themselves they will actually try to
destroy the very people who are trying
to free them Donald Trump
for all his flaws obviously was fighting
the machine that seemingly is coming for
the rest of us right now right and that
doesn't mean he can do it again it
really doesn't but he was doing it and
the media in case you didn't know it was
UN was unkind to him at best uh here is
Joy Reed on the televised mental
institution of MSNBC of course making
this all about race
the irony in sort of the karmic irony
that it is a black D.A that Donald Trump
has to face
um and that he is getting the full you
know he's being afforded all of the full
protections of the law
ah making it about race it is ironic a
black man I should note that uh Comey
was brought in by Obama but Trump kept
him and then ultimately fired him but
it's so funny that they keep calling
Trump racist and Trump's racist and it's
ironic that it's going to be a black D.A
to take him out as if he was against
black people when he was president do
you remember this moment in his State of
the Union Address what this is one of
the most iconic moments of his
presidency because it so exposes the
absolute farce of the left the corporate
media people like Joy Reed etc etc
and something I'm very proud of
African-American unemployment stands at
the lowest rate ever recorded
[Applause]
strange you got Paul Ryan and Mike Pence
standing up applauding low black
unemployment that's pretty good oh black
people are Americans low unemployment
that's really great Keith Ellison a
bunch of the other people there well
Keith Ellison was picking his nose but
uh the rest of them there they sat there
and uh at another point during that
State of the Union they showed the
Congressional Black Caucus and they all
sit there like this because they're
actually not into low black unemployment
if it is done by a republican because
they're in this thing for power
and really nothing else so what is the
end goal culturally and politically uh
when you have this Rod like what does
this actually lead to well it leads to I
would say a type of tyranny where we
will have Law Without order right we
will have the flooding of the country
with people that will just come in and
have nothing to do with American values
they will just believe they can just be
here endlessly and do whatever they want
and guess what when you once you cross
that border illegally in the first place
you've already broken the law we're
starting at a place where you've broken
the law okay uh so I want to show you
this video uh this is well you want to
do this all right yeah I jumped ahead
for just a second let's let's slow down
let's go back to Trump for just a second
uh here is Trump's attorney yesterday
sorry we got a little crossed up there
uh here's Trump's attorney yesterday uh
his name is Joe takapina uh talking
about how the rule of law has basically
died with this case
of this indictment shows that the rule
of law died in this country because
while everyone is not above the law no
one's below it either and if this man's
name was not Donald J Trump there is no
scenario we'd all be here today please
understand it okay so again without
getting into all the details of all I
think the 34 charges and how it now
turns out that a whole bunch of them
really are misdemeanors that they've
pushed up to felonies and that they are
already past the point when they should
even be allowed to legally charge him
and everything else I think it's fairly
obvious to most people if his name was
not Donald Trump as the lawyer is saying
nobody would be caring about this nobody
cares about the porn star payment now
Stormy Daniels actually has to pay Trump
back for some of this stuff like this is
clearly for political purposes new the
corrupt New York D.A who is funded by
George Soros
he is doing what he set out to do the
day he was sworn in which is take out
Donald Trump so you get a bunch of
people who do things purely for
political purposes so our justice system
which is supposed to be blind you know
the blind lady with the thing you know
that lady it's supposed to be blind it
is no longer blind and maybe it hasn't
been blind for quite some time but in
this case it certainly is not blind but
then what else do you get when you get
people who just come in for power who
just come in for an ideology not for
how about America like what is actually
best in this country uh here is video of
our Department of Homeland and security
uh secretary Alejandro mayorkas uh
basically saying that there is a reason
that we're not protecting the Border
kinda sort of maybe
the first weeks in office the Biden
Administration halted deportations for
100 days stopped all border wall
construction and suspended the remaining
Mexico policy critics say it all added
up to putting a come in we're open sign
on the door I don't think that the more
than million people last year that we
removed or expelled would consider the
Border open but the messaging was the
messaging wrong there that you know
we're open that wasn't our messaging but
that was the but that's the migrants
we're getting because remember something
that we are not the only source of
messages that the migrants receive
okay I don't know what he means by that
but the point is we know you guys know
it we didn't even have to show you more
Clips on this the amount of uh border
crossings that are happening right now
millions of them were this year than if
you took the last couple years combined
and certainly way more than When Donald
Trump was was president but what did
they do when Donald Trump said he was
going to build a wall and why was he
going to build a wall you either have a
country or you don't you a country is a
nation-state that has a delineated
border from another country so we are
not Mexico there is a There's an actual
border it's an agreed upon border by
both countries right and if you cross
that border illegally you have now
broken the law and we are allowed to
kick you out that's what a mature
responsible country would do that's what
countries in Eastern Europe are doing
right now that's what countries like
Poland and Hungary are doing they're
saying we are going to protect our
borders we don't care if you call us
races blah blah blah when Trump tried to
do it basically the entire system tried
to take him out I think you can see how
this is connected to where we started
with it showed that these are these are
unserious people these are not people
who want to celebrate doing what is
right and getting out there and getting
yours and and having Law and Order
because that's a piece of your ability
to get out there and get yours but why
doesn't majorcus think that Biden wants
a border here there's a great answer on
this one this is this is just like
wizard level go ahead
is there anything that's off the table
that you won't do to secure the Border
well the president uh as I think you
know very well said we are not going to
construct more wall that costs billions
and billions of dollars that is
immovable
is there anything you won't do yeah I
won't build a wall
because that's the thing that would
probably do it that does make it much
more complex by the way I'm not even
sitting here telling you that a wall
completely is the way to do it you know
you'd also have to use imminent domain
to move farms and move people out of
their houses on certain border areas
there might be a lot of ways that we can
do it electronically and with certain
levels of monitoring and have a certain
amount of of military down there and
everything else but like the one thing
we will do is the wall you know it's
funny when we moved into this house on
one side of our house we didn't have a
wall and we have a dog
Clyde and Clyde likes iguanas and Clyde
likes squirrels and birds and other such
things and every time I let Clyde out
I'd have to run down the block because
Clyde would leave and then you're not
going to believe what we built
anyone want to guess
there's a wall
it was a wall it was an immovable wall
Clyde has not been able to get out since
then
and the birds and iguana well the birds
are flying over but the iguanas are
having trouble getting in they figure
out a way but you get the point people
it's just ridiculous but there seems to
be a tyranny coming no matter what it's
not only sort of the ineptitude of these
people when it comes to the border and
not not caring that we should have laws
they don't care that we have laws
another thing that they do is they sign
things into law that will take away our
rights we talked about this a little bit
last week while I was in DC but there
was this restrict act that is being
pushed through Congress right now
originally this came out as a bill that
was going to in essence was going to
make Tick-Tock illegal in the United
States that's where it started and a lot
of people were saying at the beginning
of it oh this is good because Tick Tock
we know is basically Chinese spyware
that has access to everything on your
phone all of your data and your contacts
and your Communications and all that
young people are using this like we have
no real level of understanding standing
of what China is doing with that data
and everything else like it's actually
becoming a national security risk that
didn't stop Joe Biden from having Dylan
Mulvaney and a bunch of other trans
tick-tockers show up at the White House
but okay fine what of course now we have
found out because every time the
government tries to do something it
makes everything worse the restrict Act
is deeply deeply dangerous it is not
just about keeping Tick Tock off your
phone it actually is about controlling
you basically at every possible level
here is my friend David Sachs on the
all-in podcast explaining the full
effect of this in essence legalized
tyranny that they're going through with
the restrict Act
I think this is the biggest bait and
switch that Washington the central
government's ever tried to pull on us
everybody thinks that they're just
trying to ban Tick Tock from operating
the US and if that's all they did then I
think the bill would be supported by
most Americans but that's not what
they're doing they're not restricting
Tick Tock they're restricting us that's
not the goal here yeah but a bait switch
it's a huge bait and switch and so just
so you know what the ACT provides is
that a U.S citizen using a VPN to access
Tick Tock could theoretically be
subjected to a maximum penalty of one
million in fines or 20 years in prison
or both now
you know they'll say you know Mark
Warner the sponsored legislation will
swear up and down down that's not the
intent but the problem is the language
of the bill is so vague that some clever
prosecutor may want to pursue this
Theory one day and that needs to be
stopped also there's another problem
with the bill which is you think this is
just about Tick Tock it's not what they
do is it says here I guess they don't
want to mention Tick Tock by name so
they're trying to create a category of
threatening application but because it
is a category it's very very broad so
the bill states that it covers any
transaction transaction not just an app
in which an entity described instead of
paragraph B has any interest and then
entities described in some paragraph B
are quote a foreign adversary and entity
subject to the jurisdiction of
organizing the laws of a foreign
adversary an entity owned director
controlled by either of these and then
it gives the Executive Branch the power
to name a foreign adverse Siri
any foreign government regime that one
of the cabinet secretaries defines
without any vote of Congress
okay so I I know there's a bit of uh
mumbo jumbo in there and I don't want to
get too technical with this but in
essence this is what the government does
with everything we have this sort of
roughly right idea that we should get
Tick-Tock off Americans phones because
it's Chinese spyware and certainly off
young people's phones there's a whole
other reason for that because of what
they're pushing with all the trans
nonsense and everything else where they
don't push that on Tick Tock in China in
China they have these kids doing these
incredible mathematical equations and
all of this science and everything else
that's what they push to their own
people but to us it's all about you know
the gender craziness and everything else
that's one thing what David's really
referring to there is that within the
language it basically is saying any
communication that you have any uh
Commerce that you do with anyone once
someone in the government is like well
we don't like that company because maybe
they weren't doing enough for diversity
equity and inclusion we're going to
label them an enemy they will be able to
come for you do you understand that they
will be able to look at your phone see
who you're texting who who you're
sending money to what websites you're
going to and again and this is where a
certain set of not very bright people
always say well if I'm not doing
anything wrong if I'm not doing anything
legal well then I have nothing to worry
about
first off they will find something you
know what I mean they will make it up
and what is socially Norm normed today
will be dangerous tomorrow that's how
the whole thing works and by the way
this push
to silence us and make sure that they
can monitor who we communicate with and
who we uh do transactions with and
commerce with it's happening all over
the place uh the country that that maybe
much of this started with years ago and
you may know that Jordan Peterson guy
who was warning that this was happening
in Canada and everyone started calling
him a right-wing Maniac well Canada is
going down fast here is the minute I
mean this just this title alone
this woman her name is Marcy Lynn she is
the minister for women and gender
equality and youth she goes by they them
pronouns and here she is basically
coming after everyone's Free Speech this
is extraordinary and look at the
collection of people behind her in this
video take a look
firstly it enables the Attorney General
to create a 2s
lgbtqi plus Community safety zone to
prohibit within 100 meters of the
property any homophobic transphobic Act
of intimidation threat offensive threats
offensive remarks protest disturbance
and distribution of hate propaganda
within the meaning of the criminal code
it also comes with it a penalty of
twenty five thousand dollars if
prosecuted successfully
so this is what's happening in Canada
they will come for your free speech they
will decide what hate speech is who's
allowed to say what and literally where
physically they are allowed to say it
and I have just no doubt whether this
passes right now or not it will pass
eventually that is the path that Canada
is on uh just for shits and giggles as
they say I know a whole bunch of you are
watching that going well what is that
lay them lady talking about what the
hell is 2s
lgbtqia plus we googled it it's an
acronym for two spirit well all right so
first off what's two Spirits does anyone
here know what two spirit is two spirit
literally like I'm actually not kidding
at the moment I honestly have no idea
so what does it mean
Brock is two spirit he doesn't even know
what it means he just felt like he had
to identify was like all right so no one
in this room knows what two-spirited
means okay fine uh lesbian we know what
lesbians are everyone knows what
lesbians are
you've got your rose you're not
Roseanne's Roseanne's not a lesbo you
got your uh Rosie O'Donnell's you got
your Ellen DeGeneres's big lesbians you
got your gays okay we can figure that
out bisexuals they're just having a good
time you got your uh transgenders okay
you got your queer now did what what is
queer that is separate from this like
you're if you're doing any of that other
stuff you're a little queer like we got
to put a word in there for you uh oh
queer and or questioning so you're just
like I don't know let's just have a
drink and see what happens and then
there's the uh the intersex what's
intersex that means you have
you gotta Wang and a hoo-ha that's a lot
I'll give those people a pass I feel
like that's a lot on the plate you know
what I mean and then you've got asexual
which is like what you want to have sex
with cardboard or something you just
over humans and the plus reflects the
countless affirmative ways in which
people choose to self-identify
you remember the beginning of the show I
know memories are broken these days but
remember the beginning of the show and I
said you know if you're an adult
and you're still thinking about the
that happened to you in sixth grade you
got something to deal with that's what
they are doing when I say they are in
Fanta infantilizing an entire generation
of people these people look you look
people can be different some people are
gay some people are lesbians some people
are too spirited I suppose
you don't have to push everything onto
all of society but also if you if you
were religiously I would say cult-like
in your Devotion to this Obsession like
you might want to think about where it
all went wrong
right live your life as you see fit get
out of the way of other people stop
pushing everything onto everybody
but they cannot stop these people cannot
stop so so it's like all right what can
we do what can we do to change the
course of this country you know that
happened to be happens to be happening
in Canada but obviously America exports
a lot of this stuff sometimes Canada
exports uh exports it to us but what can
you do well I I would suppose first
first
you can change yourself right like
there's a way to do something right you
probably can't change the country
overnight but you might be able to do a
little something with yourself and at
the end of the day your country whether
you're watching this in America right
now or Canada or Mexico or Brazil or
Jordan your country is defined by your
culture that's what the people cultivate
that's what they say is acceptable
that's what they say is good or not good
that's what they Foster that's what they
expand one of the things that we've done
in America is expand that that sense of
freedom to more and more people so is
there a blueprint for this that's the
question right I'm always talking about
that Florida blueprint well is there a
blueprint to actually fix
the culture and I would say over the
years there have been some people who
have tried to do that there have been
people who have sort of
from a political position have tried to
say to people you have a little skin in
the game on this so let's go back 60
years ago do you remember John F Kennedy
do you remember this speech
and so my fellow Americans
ask not
what your country can do for you ask
what you can do for your country
my fellow citizens of the world
ask not
what America will do for you
but what together we can do for the
freedom of man
[Applause]
so remember that slow descent to Hell
we've been talking about think how
different America today is from that
America
think about it for just a second if
Bernie Sanders or even Joe Biden
went on stage
and said that
they would be
taken out they would be canceled it
would be as simple as that because the
whole idea their whole ethos now is the
country should do something for you
remember that clip we played yesterday
of Jon Stewart and he was talking to
Gavin Newsom about jailing people and
they were like well you know we don't we
don't cherish the human being it's like
that has nothing to do with government
you have some autonomy over your life
that's what JFK is saying don't wait for
the government to do something for you
do something for yourself then you'll
start doing something for government and
you will have built a bottom-up
institution that will that will do right
by you and right by your family and then
you'll be able to live out a Gillette
commercial from the 80s where you'll be
able to go to the moon and shot put and
meet a woman and do whatever else you
want to do so how do you do all that
first
what could Colin Kaepernick do in his
life right now so that he stops thinking
that his parents were racist and that
has somehow made his life so miserable
despite all the fame in the millions of
dollars well you know what he could do
he could try fixing himself that might
do it
Jordan Peterson has had a little bit to
say about that over the years here is
his first apportion of his first prayer
you video from 2018.
blaming others for your problems is a
complete waste of time when you do that
you don't learn anything you can't grow
and you can't mature
thus you can't make your life better
in my three decades as a professor in
clinical psychologist
I've learned that there are two
fundamental attitudes toward life and
its sorrows
those with the first attitude blame the
world
those with the second ask what they
could do differently why
because other people aren't the problem
you're the problem
you can't change other people but you
can change yourself
but it's difficult it takes courage to
change and it takes discipline
now there are people who seem to be
consigned to a terrible fate but most of
us aren't
most of us have a chance to make our
lives better but how
start small
ask yourself a few questions
have you taken full advantage of the
opportunities offered to you
are you working to your fullest capacity
at school or at work
have you in other words
set your own house in order
if the answer is no
try this
stop doing what you know to be wrong
stop today the proper way to fix the
world isn't to fix the world
there's no reason to assume that you're
even up to such a task
but you can fix yourself
you'll do no one any harm by doing so
and in that manner at least you will
make the world a better place
I hope you see what we tried to do on
the show today I know this wasn't purely
political today I suppose this was a
little more psychology or spiritual or
self-help or something but this is
connected to a society that would drag
out a former ex-president and who hopes
to be a future president and and put him
on trial so that we end up in some
Banana Republic situation a whole bunch
of people
who instead of fixing themselves
decided to just be part of a very
corrupt system
and if we do some of those things
imagine if cap Colin Kaepernick instead
of whining about everything did some of
the things that Jordan talked about
there if those drag queens that want to
perform in perform in front of kids or
the DA's or the politician in Canada
who's so upset about people who might
say something within 200 yards of an
lgbtqi double Spirit Center want to say
imagine if any of these people
did what Jordan said
stop doing what was wrong in their life
whatever that might be and then started
fixing their life you know where we
could end up we could end up where we
started this show at we could end up in
a world that we had that was pretty well
illustrated by that Gillette commercial
from the 1980s so we're going to show it
to you again right now
you're looking sharp you're looking good
you've come so far
we know how to make
the most of Who You Are
always
[Music]
so many faces it's plain to see
we give you all we have to
have
where the race is wrong
[Music]
at Contour plus with lubricating strip
to the best a man can get
the rubic report
that is our show for you today I hope
you enjoyed it a little bit different
today I think we tried to there's got to
be a way out that's not just political
that's what I think I think you think it
too and we just got to figure it out and
if we can all do a little bit of that we
can all start shot putting and jumping
hurdles and a whole bunch more together
uh guys if you didn't catch it I did a
live show uh post Trump indictment with
Lisa Booth yesterday we did that at the
local Studio here in Miami Fox News
contributor Lisa Booth I just adore her
she's she's absolutely fantastic so if
you haven't seen that check it out we
leave you cold clothes Alvin Bragg sorry
and uh
post game show in 32 seconds see ya
Manhattan grand jury on 34 felony counts
falsifying business records in the first
degree under New York state law it is a
felony to falsify business records with
intent to the fraud and an intent to
conceal another crime
that is exactly what this case is about
34 false statements
made to cover up other crimes if these
are felony crimes in New York state
no matter who you are we cannot and will
not normalize serious criminal contracts
[Music]